the truth is all we have in life the
truth is the most important thing that
we could ever learn about ourselves
honesty is the only glue that keeps
together communities on the internet and
I want to talk about the truth because I
want to talk about why I make videos
like feeling down and if you've been
with my channel for a while you know
that videos like feeling down are not
uncommon because I'm the kind of guy
that wears his heart on his sleeve I
show my emotions at every turn because I
want to be honest not just with you guys
but with myself I want to be honest
because in that honesty I want people to
realize that doubting yourself is not
always a bad thing if you let it consume
your life of course if you doubt
yourself to the point of crippling
anxiety you're never gonna go anywhere
but doubting yourself means that you're
not so much of a fool that you're
walking forward thinking that you're
always right because if you think that
you're always right
you are more often wrong than right and
if you're moving through life with that
blind confidence you're never gonna go
anywhere
and no one's ever gonna trust you and I
know there's people that watch my videos
that have no interest in playing any
bigger role than just watching my videos
for entertainment value and that's fine
I try to make the best most entertaining
videos that I possibly can given the
time frame that I have in my life to do
them but also beyond that one of the
coolest thing that's ever come out of
this channel is the ability to be honest
with each other
the ability for me to talk to you guys
about my feeling at any given time and
be honest and not try to always put it
in a positive light there are times when
I have doubts about myself there are
times when you guys have doubts about
yourselves about each other about this
community about where we're going but
what always matters is that you trust
that we're always moving forward we're
always trying to make the world a better
place we're always trying to put forward
goodwill in the world we're always
trying to shrug off those doubts not
ignore them acknowledge them realize if
they're right or wrong
correct because of them and then move
forward in life no matter what no matter
what obstacles are coming your way
always moving forward and listen close
because this is very important we are
doing great things on this channel when
I came from a place of crippling
self-doubt I moved forward from that
doubt to a place where I can be proud of
the things that I have done and if I
leave anything behind in this world it
is the idea that that can come from
anywhere anyone can do what I have done
anyone can be the person that I have
become not a copy of myself but pushing
yourself to a higher place pushing
yourself to a better version of you
making sure that those doubts don't
bring you down don't [ __ ] your
development don't make you move like
it's so afraid of moving forward and so
afraid of what people think of you that
you do nothing in your life that doesn't
mean that everybody will find success
but that does mean that everybody can
take the risks to develop themselves to
a place where they are proud of what
they can do that is what's important
about this channel that's what's
important about being honest with
ourselves that's what's important about
being honest with each other and that's
what I love about this channel that's
what I absolutely love about creating
things on the Internet
that's what I love about this community
and that doesn't mean that everything's
positive on the internet that doesn't at
all because there are shitty people who
discover that they are shitty people no
matter what they do and that's fine too
but it's our responsibility to try to
push humanity forward that's what I want
more of I want to see humanity go to
great places I want to see us live up to
our potential I want to see us move
forward into a brighter future i Macias
succeed in places that we doubt we can
go that's what I want that's what I've
always wanted so anyway you guys know I
love to ramble but I've got some
important things to talk about so listen
up and listen up closely there is a
charity stream that we're going to be
doing on December 1st this is going to
be a big one we have so much in the way
of charity merch this year we've got
these lovely lovely mustache lights that
light up because their lights call them
Christmas lights or call them I don't
know just balls their balls but not just
that
for Christmas we've got ugly Christmas
sweaters we've got this lovely design
and green and red it's the Christmas
giggly [ __ ] shirt it's beautiful it's
horrible it's incredibly ugly and you
are gonna be proud to wear it all
proceeds go to stand up to cancer but
it's not only available in green it's
available in black as well black and red
it's super cool I highly recommend it
but we're not done because we've also
got the lower body yes
markiplier sweatpants are finally here
they're not pajama pants but you could
wear them as pajama plants there are a
little over light weight they're not
thick and heavy so they're not gonna be
super hot but they are warm and cozy
they've got pockets they've got a back
pocket they've got a drawstring and the
pockets are pretty substantial so get
them for yourselves they're gonna be
available on December 1st but that's not
all
shoelaces I know you guys have always
wanted the shoelaces that's what you're
always talking about pink and black you
can get them separately into either
color you also get one pink one black if
you wanted but also notebook and for all
your notebook needs it's got a clasp
they're all pink bookmark and unlined
pages for all your journaling and/or
doodling needs no I ruined it
socks are back socks socks all of this
is coming December 1st all of these
items are going to be sold for charity I
I'm not gonna make a penny off of any of
these items every single thing goes to
charity so if you want to support the
charity and that stand up to cancer go
there
December 1st right here on YouTube 10:00
a.m. Pacific Standard Time and this is
where I really need you to pay attention
anyone who's even remotely artistically
enabled or if you're not make posters
make pieces of art that have the
information December 1st
10:00 a.m. Pacific Standard Time stand
up to cancer
all merch items on markiplier comm will
go to charity I will not make any money
use like cutouts of transparent images
of myself
use your favorite meme of me use
anything that you could possibly get
your hands on about me to promote this
charity stream it's gonna be big we're
gonna have guest stars on it we're gonna
have a lot of fun we're gonna be playing
games we're gonna be doing live-action
stuff we've got other things planned
surprises going on it'll be a great time
and it'll be a great time for a great
cause but I need your help to do it I
need anyone anyone that even isn't
remotely artistically inclined you can
still help out by sharing these various
posters that other people are making and
cross feed it to your timelines if
you've got Twitter retweet if you've got
tumblr reblog if you've got facebook
share if you've got any sort of social
media even if people don't even know who
the [ __ ] I am tell them that there's a
charity event where we're gonna be
raising the most money possible for
Stand Up to Cancer I don't even have a
goal but I want to blow it out of the
water this year last year we raised
$400,000 for charity I want to do more
than that we are gonna show the people
by force if we have to that there's good
to be done and there was ways to move
forward and there's no one that's gonna
stop us from doing some good and it's
gonna be great so thank you everybody so
much for watching thank you for your
kind words on the last video I am fine
by the way just because I say that I'm
feeling down it doesn't mean that I'm in
any way stopped from doing what I want
to do in doing what I love to do it's
okay
to feel down so long as you pick
yourself back up and if you're feeling
so down that you don't think you can
rely on your friends rely on your family
rely on others and then pick yourself
back up so thank you everybody so much
for watching thank you so much for being
here remember December 1st 10:00 a.m.
Pacific Standard Time be there and
thanks again and as always I will see
you in the next video bye bye